hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the saint louis rapid and
blitz tournament uh it is the second day
of the rapids and it is
versus
uh young had a fairly fairly decent
first day he got two wins in one draw uh
mamidarov on the other hand uh he lost
two games and got one draw so he really
would enjoy bouncing back especially
with the black pieces against nepo uh
the potential future world champion uh
so it's a really wild game uh it
features the catalan you you guys will
like it and there are uh there's a
certain position where uh
pretty much every move you make is
winning which is very odd as there are
weird moves you can make so you'll see
what i mean by this now let's dive
straight into it jan has the white
pieces and he opens with d4
we have knight f6 by shock c for e6
knight to f3 not allowing the nimzo
indian and now pawn to d5 uh just
transposing into the queen's gambit
decline we have g3 nepo opts for the
catalan defend uh the catalan opening
and now uh bishop to be for witchcraft
we have bishop to d2 and now bishop back
to e7 uh bishop to g2 in the balls
players castle so castles castles and
now knight beat the d7 queen to c2 and
now c6 so there were a couple of um
weird lines but uh they just transposed
into the normal catalan and this is
something that's played very very often
uh the differences here the top moves
that people usually play are bishop f4
rook to d1 and just a nice b3 but nepo
goes for the immediate h4 and now it's
not a new move but it's only been played
a handful of times so let's see how
momodaro deals with this we have quanta
b6 preparing bishop to a6 as the rook is
still
on f1 so you might have trouble
defending this knight to c3 and bishop
to a6 now also putting pressure on the c
for pawn so here we have a trade
captures captures and now just rook f2c1
and there is a game uh between
grigorioperin and ray robson also from
uh st louis summer a event that was
played this year that ended in a draw
where queen to b8 was played but here we
have bishop back to b7 by mamidarov and
it is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so you're probably
wondering this looks very very timid how
can this game be in any way exciting
well that's what chess is all about you
know few moves and everything just
explodes so here we have bishop to f4
you know it makes sense uh jan has a
queen and a rook on the c file makes
sense to go rook to c8 we have queen to
b3 and now pawn to a6 preparing b5 so of
course nepo stops this and now pawn to
h6 taking away the g5 square uh from
nepal's pieces we have e3 and now just
knight to h5 going after the bishop here
this will mess up nepo's pawn structure
but this is kind of exactly what nepo
wanted so bishop to h3 now if knight
captures you can simply play pawn
captures and you will have a firm grip
on the e5 square you will put the knight
on e5 and you will have a very very good
position if this knight can get
somewhere to g4 maybe the queen gets
into the attack so it could be very very
difficult to defend this so after bishop
to h3 mamijaro goes rook to c4 prepares
rook to b4 to kick away the queen or if
you attack the rook then rook to b4 and
now queen back to d1 now you are
threatening maybe some discoveries with
the knight as the the this knight might
be hanging but still black can always
capture uh here so it's not really an
issue uh mamijarov goes for it right
away knight captures on e4 e captures uh
sorry on f4 e captures on f4 and now
bishop the d6 and here just bishop to f1
uh kicking that rook away from such an
active square rook to c7 and now bishop
back to d7
and now
you can already see that for example if
let's say
bishop goes to c2 win goes to d3 there
will be a constant checkmating threat
against the black king so knight to f6
you definitely wanted this knight here
and not just the guard h7 but also to
have uh keep an eye on the e4 square
queen to e2 and now queen to a8 uh
adding another well basically more
pressure on the c4 square so the knight
at some point will land on e4 so knight
to e5 and not just rook f to c8 nicely
doubling up on the c file f3 taking away
the f4 square from the black knight and
now pawn to h5 stopping g4 as if white
starts pushing those pawns uh black will
just get obliterated because all of
white all of maduro's pieces are on the
queen side so here we have queen to e3
now queen to e3 a very nice move as
you'll see you could also maybe i just
uh start with the doubling of the rooks
but nepo has a very very clear idea uh
so queen to e3 bishop to b for now kind
of putting pressure on c3 but not really
now that the queen is on e3 this is
impossible just rook to c2 and now of
course point is that uh it seems like
you can win material here but the
problem is this bishop to h7 check for
those of you who are maybe new to chess
if you grab the pawn here just captures
capture the bishop to h7 check will uh
pick up the rook here so for example
knight captures or king captures queen
captures on c3 and you're just up the
exchange you have a rook for a bishop of
course this will be completely winning
for ian so here after rook the c2
mamadarov should consider
playing it uh you know just quietly just
something like a5 um improving the
position uh but uh the question is what
happens if f5 is played f5 is such a
dangerous move that you kind of don't
want to see it but you you kind of have
to allow it and here uh mamadirov plays
g6 but this is what we call in chess uh
basically seeing ghosts uh he wanted to
prevent f5 so he played the g6 but by
playing g6 he actually invites f5 as now
it is much more potent not right away
but of course nipple will first prepare
it so here we have rook 8 to c1 now just
to give you an idea as this is a rapid
game of course players only have 15
minutes on the clock but just to give
you an idea of how dangerous the
position is uh g4 here
and there now f5 is coming and there's
no defending this position whatever you
play let's say rook to f8 uh just f5 and
how are you defending this the queen now
has access to g5 to h6 this is
unstoppable if e captures you're just
going to play g captures again you're
going to capture here
no move for mamijaro if queen e8 doesn't
really matter just f capture spawn
captures rook to g2 and the black just
gets obliterated here so okay after g6
we have rook 8 to c1 like i said it's a
rapid game you can't really calculate
all the pawn pushes uh so uh might be
very dangerous but still rocket the c1
does not uh uh you know ruin in any way
nepal's chances of pushing g4 at some
point so king to g7 and now comes bishop
captures on g6 and this is a beautiful
move g4 also very much playable but nepo
has a different idea he plays a bishop
captures on g6 f captures and now queen
to d3 just going after that g6 pawn uh
but the difference is in this variation
uh that mummy arab has this very very
annoying defensive idea of knight to e4
and now and apple will have to really
find the
unique moves in order to win this
position so f captures on e4 now comes d
captures on e4 this also will open up uh
mamadirov's diagonal here
so queen to e3 uh keeping the pawn
blocked and now you have to in order to
continue playing this with my with black
you have to play bishop to d6 however
mahmoud makes what could be described as
uh well one of the one of the worst
moves maybe that was played this year in
rapid or maybe in general i don't know
but it's a move that after he plays it
it's such a normal looking move and it's
a move that of course
everyone would want to play that is
bishop to d5 but not pretty much any
move uh nepo uh makes wins the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find any move that wins the game i mean
there are some that don't but try to
find at least one that does uh while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh finding uh
either g4 or f5 or knight captures and
g6 or uh uh well
those are the nice ones uh and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
uh nipple played pawn to g4 but as it's
such a rich position
i will show you why some of the other
moves are winning for example knight
captures and g6 is really just a
wonderful variation point being that
after king captures you just play f5
check and now the queen gets access to
the g5 square but even better after he
captures on f5 there's knight captures
on d5 are you grabbing a knight and not
threatening rook captures on c7 so black
naturally will have to capture on c2 and
now queen g5 check king f7 queen
captures with check king to e8 queen the
e6 king to d8 and now pretty much
anything again wins queen to g8 check
you have to go to d7 and now a beautiful
triple fork here that knight to b6 check
king to c6 you're even gonna capture on
c2 king captures and now rook captures
or queen captures depending on how you
want to play it let's say rook captures
queen b7 and now a nice queen to d8 to
check and your automotive queen to c7
you just capture with checkmate and if
king here then you win the black queen
and then you checkmate the black king so
uh that's uh how you win with knight
captures and g6 also another fun move is
pawn to f5 uh
and again nothing to do if g captures it
then the queen gets axis and the queen
and knight checkmate the black king if e
captures then there's again knight
captures on d5 that's why this uh bishop
on d5 is such a such a terrible piece as
it always loses a piece for uh for mom
and dad there's no move that he can make
you can't go for the knight because the
rook is now hanging with check and if
you go for the rook uh that you kind of
have to do let's say captures not just
knight captures on b4 now you have two
knights for the rook also yeah it's very
unlikely that you will survive this
queen g5 is coming uh it's completely
winning but nipple goes for the third
option after bishop to d5 which is cool
uh as it shows that absolutely every
move is winning he plays g4 and uh there
is no way to stop this h captures on g4
and now rook to g2 this is uh a
different approach but also an
unstoppable one just real captures real
characters there's no way uh to defend
this rook to h7 now comes to rook
captures on g4 also knight captures on
g4 as possible followed by f5 and queen
to h6 uh but okay rook captures on g4
rook the g8 now defends the g6 pawn
but not just king h2 now the other rook
will come to the g file as well we have
queen to c8
and now uh the final push pawn to f5 and
now again uh what do you play uh if you
play g captures then you've pretty much
opened up the entire position just
captures captures knight captures and d5
is game over uh the rook is hanging also
if you capture the rook then knight to
f6 check wins the queen you get
checkmated uh this is of course
impossible so uh what uh
actually happened in the game uh uh was
it was g captures on f5 but it went
differently but if e captures on f5 then
knight captures on d5 immediately that's
basically what i wanted to show you uh
point is again if rook captures on c1
it's just a beautiful forced checkmate
knight f6 check king g7 rook captures
now the knight is defended and the rook
is guarded king to f8 queen to h6 check
this is just incredible knight to d5
back with check king the eighth now rook
capture sanji check and that's it you
have to block with the bishop it's the
only move and now queen or rook captures
will be checkmate so look at the these
nights i mean absolutely incredible
absolute monsters here so point being
after f5 g captures on f5 was played we
have rook captures and now not queen
captures but king captures on g8 and now
queen to g5 with check we have rook to
g7
and now only now that rook blocked check
and uh nipples queen is hanging nepal
plays knight captures on d5 and he was
in this position on move 39 that chakri
armadaro resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh so
that's why the bishop on d5 was such a
such a terribly placed piece i mean it
was uh it's been a while since we've
seen um a piece placed so terribly that
i mean you could look you could
literally play anything like you know if
you if you let your cat on the board and
the cat you know move the piece it would
probably be winning uh so again the idea
is the same your queen is hanging and
also the knights are just ready to start
checking the black king if you go for
captures on c1 just queen to d8 to check
it's a nice force checkmate king to h7
knight f6 check only move king h6 now
comes queen to h8 with check and now you
have to block and this will be checkmate
and the other moves don't really help
you if you try and bring your queen to
help out with the defense again just
knight f6 and it's the same idea maybe
even faster king h8 queen to h6 check uh
rook h7 and now queen captures and h7
will be checkmate so after night
captures on the five beautiful move uh
mamijaro resigns and another beautiful
beautiful uh spectacular victory for
yanni pomnishi who uh i'm not sure about
the standings but i think he caught up
to all it is i'm not sure how um already
i was doing as alireza also won uh two
games yesterday one again uh one also
against shakhtar mamidarov and one
against hikaru nakamura but we're gonna
cover more games so we're gonna check
out the standings at some point if you
have a game that you like use hashtag
suggestion and i will uh
make sure to go through it uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh the first game that we've covered
from the saint louis rapids tournament
after that we have the blitz uh i would
like to thank chris basil gregoriobala
connor kelly john merlino and the daemon
targaryen for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day